Louis eights Lapham author of the wish
for Kings democracy at bay you have a
chapter called Versailles on the Potomac
what's it about it's about the splendor
of Washington that has been the
magnificence of its marble of its
pretensions of its bureaucratic vastness
so it has become like a palace at
Versailles I mean it is a court society
a world unto itself sometimes called
inside the beltway and it's grown and
multiplied since the end of the Second
World War so that the expense of
government the number of functionaries
of people who serve government in its in
its many facets I mean I think there's
something like now a hundred thousand
lawyers and lobbyists that work on
various degrees of regulation and the
Congress the staff of the Congress has
multiplied to thirty five thousand
minutes it's this sense of a vast
Versailles like court a Hall of Mirrors
in which the various servants of
government flattered one another or
blame one another strike poses issue
bills make announcements staged pageants
of one kind or another that that's the
view of it in that chapter you have a
story in here about Robert mossbacher
the former Secretary of Commerce I do
when Massa Becker first came to he was
appointed by Bush and he came from
Houston and he thought that a man of his
stature and magnificence should have had
more notice by the media more time on
television more space in the Washington
Post and so on and so he was constantly
seeking means of his own
self-aggrandizement and he hit upon
having a private entrance made for
himself at the Department of Commerce on
the other side of the building from the
come from the entrance in which the the
mirror populace was to come and go and
he and he had the entrance built at
great expense with a long morning sort
of like a canopy in front of a nightclub
or a restaurant and I think he wanted to
have it read because Jim Baker's canopy
at the State Department was blue or he
wanted it blue because Jim Baker's
canopy was red I can't remember which
way it went but there are only six
people allowed to use that entrance it
was mas Becker himself his wife his
secretary his deputy his lawyer for all
I know his valid and then after he'd
gotten that all together it still wasn't
quite grand enough he practiced working
in and out of the that entrance for a
number of weeks and then he decided that
still that just once he got inside the
building there was a distance to go to
his own private elevator but between the
entrance and the elevator there were
offices sort of cubicles in which the
poor people worked were you the short
sleeves I mean it was an unseemly
display of manual labor so he had the
entire inside of the Department of
Commerce that part of it anyway
reconstructed the offices were moved so
that there was a properly open grand
space between the entrance and the
elevator I believe that that was a table
put there with a simply a decoration of
flowers but it's that kind of attitude
that too often captures people I mean
not only of course in Washington but
elsewhere in the in within any
organization large enough to sustain its
own theory of reality Nancy Reagan the
color red and a bed she used to have her
own bed or a replica when she traveled
with the president she would have a
better one exactly like it carried a few
days before she was going to arrive in
some foreign capital and she also was
unless you probably well remember she
the color red was a passion of hers so
that the rooms in which she was to stay
whether she was going to a palace in
Venice or a castle in France or a hotel
in Hawaii the rooms the room was painted
red prior to her arrival and her bed was
placed the room was painted and then the
mirrors were all dropped because Nancy
Reagan was was fairly short and
sometimes the mirrors had to be brought
down to a level that so she saw more
than the top of her head which would
otherwise put her in bad mood for the
afternoon jack kent cooke who owns the
washington redskins you caught him
saying I'm a Republican but strangely I
have a great many Democratic friends
Dodd Brzezinski Greenspan he's of
indeterminate lineage Sam Donaldson
what's he gene McCarthy and George
McGovern what's the point here
the point is that jack kent cooke is the
owner of the washington redskins and
that one of the most valued places at
court in washington is in jack kent
cooke box at JFK RFK Stadium and it's a
large box I believe there was 50 or 60
places and of course during the long
period of a Republican administration
the box was filled with important
Republicans ad shortly after the
election of Clinton I believe within two
days suddenly it turned out Cook
discovered all of his Democratic friends
and the their seats were changed and
with a new administration the court
brings in new tortillas and cook is very
quick to to see that it's it's the
constant game in Washington as you know
far better than I whose in who's out I
mean
who who will come who will go who will
get to write the Senators speeches or
carry the general shirt or sit and jack
kent cooke spocs or have a parking space
at the national airport I mean these are
questions of vast weight you also quote
mr. cook assign the box is not used to
ingratiate myself with the
administration
please quote me this is the New York
Times actual quote please quote me
precise on that I invite people who are
good company happy cheerful
good-humoured people who love football
it's a great statement I'm sure it's
worthy of a politician but I mean it's
I'm sure you can all with people who are
in jack kent cooke spock's are apt to be
happy and cheerful and loving football
almost of necessity I mean that that
would be whether they're Democrats or
Republicans you write about the World
Bank in first class versus business
class travel what's the World Bank the
World Bank is a large lending
institution which arranges loans usually
for underdeveloped countries loans for
economic assistance and it takes most of
the funds come from the United States
and the headquarters a world banker here
in Washington but it does assemble funds
from other countries in the world and so
its mission is to the the poorer more
hard-pressed countries of the earth but
it it sustains a fairly sizable
bureaucracy of its own very comfortable
one very highly paid people and one of
these people on one of his chaunce to
some desolate heath in Africa had it
figured out that if he traveled business
class instead of first class he would
save a great deal of money and he then
worked out the equation that if this
practice was
adopted by other members of the
hierarchy of the World Bank they would
they would save 12 million dollars a
year dinner this is not too great a
decline in accommodation I mean we were
simply going from first class to
business class and saving 12 million
dollars but when this memorandum was
passed around within the corridors of
the World Bank it evoked feelings of
horror disbelief dismay had one of the
vice presidents sent back a counter memo
saying if I can't remember the exact
words but it was the effect that this
couldn't you know this sort of
suggestion was outrageous and that
Mister whoever it was didn't have more
concern for the comfort of his
colleagues he should be dismissed at
once
in return you know sent to some dark
place of Exile but it was the the
feeling of how can they take this away
from it if a story in here about Bob
gray who is he and what's his
relationship to you Bob gray was a man I
began to when I I first began I first
came to Washington in the late 1950s
during the Eisenhower administration
I come from University and I was trying
to decide what kind of career to follow
but school I'd go into Yale University
and then in the United States then I go
to Cambridge University in England on
the so I came and I talked as a very
young man I approached the CIA I
approached the Washington Post and I
also approached the White House and I
was sent to talk to mr. gray --great at
this point in time eventually became an
enormous ly successful lobbyists and
trafficker and influencing and patronage
and now as I believe he had his own
lobbying firm for many years and is now
with Hill & Knowlton
but then he was a young man and he was a
an aide to Eisenhower and I can remember
being interviewed by him he had very
little time he was he was hard pressed
and we interviewed took place in the
basement of the White House in the in
the barber shop I mean there was a
barber chair down there in those days
and the only other place for me to sit
was on the toilet i sat on the toilet
and gray sad and in the barber chair and
I was a level of his shoes which I
remember being very beautiful shoes and
he I started to talk about democratic
theory I was very young very idealistic
and gray waved that all off and sort of
said to John please don't waste
anybody's time he said the whole thing
about government about Washington about
powers is is simply to acquire the right
sort of friends and make connections and
do what you're told until the great day
comes when you can tell others what to
do carry whatever water must be carried
and so on it was a very realistic
assessment and a very clear statement of
the principle by which I never forgot I
mean he made it very articulately what
happened to Bob gray after 1957 he
became after I he that when it was I set
up his own firm and became very
influential in it in a number of Beza
lobbyists as a man who makes
introductions who arranges things who
helps legislation more easily through
the channels of the Congress and so on
lobbyists I believe is the term what
happened to you that's what I'm not
meaning I I went into the newspaper
business I became a newspaper reporter
first for the San Francisco Examiner
and then for the New York Herald Tribune
and then I became a magazine writer in
the most of the 60s for The Saturday
Evening Post and for Life magazine and
then what then I became a writer for
Harper's Magazine in about 1970 and in
1971 I became by default a managing
editor because there was a one of those
office politics things that happens in
New York magazine offices fairly
frequently so the then editor resigned
so did some of the other editors I
didn't agree with their unhappiness so I
stayed and I became on on a Monday I was
a writer at on Tuesday I became a
managing editor and I remained I was the
managing editor for four years and then
I became the editor in 1976 how long did
you stay there
well I was the editor for about let's
see from 1976 to 1981 then I was fired
and spent two years in exile and rehired
in 1980 1993 I was then the glorious
return I was I was recalled as the
editor of the magazine so I've been the
editor twice once 1976 81 and again from
83 until now you dedicate this book to
John R MacArthur who is weary of
merchants let alone Kings who is John R
McArthur John R MacArthur is the
publisher of Harper's Magazine and is a
related to the large MacArthur family
well-known family in Chicago and he
became associated with Harper's Magazine
very early when it in 1980 became
interested in the in the magazine and
it's a long story but it
when the magazine went bankrupt in 1980
it was through his influence that the
magazine was rescued first by the John R
MacArthur Foundation and then in turn by
the Harper's Magazine foundation well he
is first of all a journalist and has
himself written a good book called the
second front which he published last
year which his book about the press
coverage of the Gulf War and then he's
also the publisher of the magazine but
he's a very very good person for me to
work for because he encourages
freedom of expression I mean he's not
nervous about offending the powers that
be where's the MacArthur money come from
originally originally comes from John R
MacArthur his grandfather who was a man
who made a great fortune in a real
estate and in insurance businesses and
began to acquire his fortune in the in
the Depression in the early 1930s in the
middle of that period when you were
without a job yeah you had a dinner with
that you were invited to that just guard
to Stein the former yes in the French to
tell that story well I was again this is
I'm trying to explain that the courtier
spirit the attitude of bowing and
scraping that takes place in various
large American institutions is true of
certainly in Washington but it's also
true of quite a few Business
Corporations is true within the media
it's true in the Universities find the
word courtier courtier is one who says
to a succession of masters make of me
what you want I am what you want me to
be in other words it's in a totally a
dependent somebody willing to do
whatever is asked
I his or her boss and lives by making a
constantly gracious impression it's a
yes man would be another way of there'll
be another phrase for it anyway
the in 1981 I was the editor of the
magazine and I had been asked to a very
small dinner for at the Council on
Foreign Relations in New York for geez
guard this thing and I was invited I
believe on the 1st of August and I was
fired on the 15th of August and the
dinner was on the 15th of September in a
few days before the dinner I the council
called me up and wanted to know what
title should go after my name on that
little piece of paper that's distributed
to everybody at the dinner and of course
by that time had none gone is this long
and ghastly silence and I met I finally
managed to resolve it by saying that I
wrote an occasional article for The
Washington Post and so they were I
didn't have any permanent employment
with the post but it was enough to get
on the piece of paper well they have
invited you if you didn't have a job it
wouldn't have been probably not no I
mean the again the notion of the court
the notion of titles the notion of one
is known by one's institutional
affiliation the plain democratic name it
has to have the of Mobil Oil Corporation
of the New York Times of c-span of
Harper's Magazine of whatever I mean
it's the we as Americans like to pride
ourselves as individualist constantly in
one of the images of ourselves that we
like the best is that of the Clint
Eastwood figure or the man against the
system
cowboy faring west in the rain but we in
fact are people that are very much
dependent upon our institutional
identities and identifications I am of
the bank I am of the paper I am of the
studio whatever and this of course is
one of the premises of theses of the
book which is as the courtier spirit
which is the accommodating spirit the
Democratic spirit is the one that that
simply speaks out and says whatever it's
in its mind and candor is one of the
great democratic political virtues the
we're Democrats to the extent that we
try to tell each other what we know what
we've seen what we feel we're courtiers
to the extent that we tell each other
what we each of us want to hear and so
that that the book is is saying that as
more and more people in this country
become more and more dependent on large
institutions whereas in the last part of
the 19th century most Americans were
self employed something like 80% of the
population many of them farmers
obviously but farmers and small
craftsmen and businessmen as the in the
20th century as the large institutional
organizations come forward now I think
only 2% of the American people are are
self-employed and if you if one depends
on an instant institution for for one's
whole existence I mean not only medical
insurance but also clothes allowance
also pension also placed in the world
also business card and so forth
then the independent habit of mind tends
to give way to the more accommodating
habit of mind that's the one of the
arguments note six in the back of the
book the story of kissinger's life is
the story of the perfect courtier
Kissinger was a man who knew how to play
the court world extremely well I mean he
began as a he was discovered by Nelson
Rockefeller when he'd been a Kissinger
started as an academic he was at Harvard
history professor I believe and then
somehow he managed to get to Nelson
Rockefeller and he provided Nelson
Rockefeller with whatever theories
Nelson Rockefeller and governor of New
York and at presidential ambitions and
he provided him with theories of the
Cold War theories of nuclear disarmament
theories of nuclear exchange I forget in
what succession they they came but but
Kissinger again was a man always willing
to arrange the world to fit the desire
of his patron whether it was Rockefeller
or Nixon or sometimes important senior
colonists in the media I mean he
understood that it was that the world of
was a world of poses of the right word
at the right time whether the theory
actually was true or not whether had any
relation to the facts or not was less
important than the way it advanced or
failed to advance Kissinger is career
it's a little bit off the subject but
it's in your book and it's note number
twelve you talk about an advertising
executive who had to give an enema to a
client quiet once a month once a week
what in the world is that story that
story is
I'm saying that as the well it's a story
about trying to put a desk new animation
by the way in this book oh no this year
this first time it's been published this
little story yeah you found this out
fellow explain this to me yeah tell the
whole story if you don't mind well as
the story I mean the magazine business
again as people become more independent
on their patrons more willing to do what
is ever necessary to do to get the vote
or to get the part or to get the account
people who are in the position of
granting those requests begin to have
more and more refined desires and
appetites I mean it's a variation on the
whole story about the Hollywood producer
who insists that the young aspiring
actress go to bed with him before she
can get the part in this instance is the
story of a ad salesman who is dependent
on a client for a very large account a
couple of hundred thousand dollars a
year in business for the magazines in
question and the client had a weird
sexual request which required the
advertising fella to show up I think
once every two months in a motel and
somewhere in New Jersey and administer
an intimate of the gentleman so by the
way you say you had to wear a seersucker
suit a bow tie either yellow or pink
yeah there were there were certain
sartorial requirements but it's an
example of the happens to be a fairly
unhappy example were dismal example but
it there are many many examples like
that
throughout the society people that are
in power that have power over their
dependents this essentially was the
argument that between Clarence Thomas
and Anita Hill it wasn't him it was the
argument about what does the individual
in authority what can he insist upon on
the part of his subordinates you have a
letter in here I'll read just a little
bit of it dear mr. president here with
the first run off the press of a book
called the making of the president 1968
whose hero is Richard M Nixon later on
you say this gentleman says the campaign
that this book tries to describe was the
campaign of a man of courage and of
conscience and the respect it wrung from
me which I hope is evident surprised me
week by week as I went along later this
man writes there's no there's so much
difference between being a reporter and
being a citizen and his last line and
this president can also call on me as a
friend
sincerely Teddy white right why did you
put that in this book I put that in
because it I'm trying to show the
relation of the the media the press to
power which is again the relation of the
courtier trying to curry favor among the
people whom it it describes to stay
friends I mean in that particular book
white had some rather sharp things to
say about Nixon but the he he wanted to
maintain his place of Corti
I believe this is true I don't know if
this is in the book but I've been told
and I think it's true is that Kay Graham
and the Washington Post
shortly after Nixon was impeached I mean
the same month sent him a nice note and
said don't worry when it's all over
we'll we'll have dinner I mean it's it's
that relation
the relation is always to power and if
you're out of power nobody can remember
your name and if you're in power
everybody's your best friend the the the
case of Nixon's careers is a brilliant
demonstration of that I mean a man who
was considered a used car salesman
impeached and now he's twenty years ago
his name was synonymous with scoundrel
crook and now his name is synonymous
with statesman of the Philosopher's the
last line of the jacket on your book
says the several facets of this question
come in - brilliant focus in this
important book by one of our most
incisive social critics no one who cares
about the future of our nation should
miss reading the wish for Kings that
they're writing about you and the only
reason I bring that up is that you then
have a note in here that says the talent
for self-promotion is by no means unique
to Washington in New York it is common
practice for authors to write the jacket
copy for their own books that's true did
you write the jacket copy for your own
book I don't think so I certainly edited
it I mean what happens is that the the
publisher writes it and then they
submitted to the to the author and so
I'm sure I had a hand in that did you
worry about the fact that you had had a
hand in that and then use this footnote
because you're right you're critical of
a guy named a Gordon lish who wrote the
following about himself there was no
other contemporary figure in the
nation's literary community whose
presence is as widely or has urgently
felt I don't think I think it's a
question of degree I mean it's a
question I thought the lish was a little
over the top when I saw it's the words
that the publisher used that my own
behalf were fairly cliched and familiar
what about this book it's published by
Grove Harper's groped by Grove press is
that owned by harbors no it's owned by
the Atlantic Monthly so it is there's
something called the Atlantic month
press which and then there was something
called Grove Press and just about the
same time that this book was published
last this spring Harper's I mean sorry
Atlantic Monthly press acquired Grove
Press so now they're a joint publishing
company why did you want to write this
book I wanted to write the book because
I was trying to describe what I saw
not only in I was trying to report
accurately the circumstance of the when
I kept encountering I mean and again
it's not only about government it's
about universities it's about
corporations about the media and and I
don't exempt myself from the conditions
that I described but people constantly
go around and say the American democracy
is in trouble or the United States is in
decline and so forth and it seems to me
that if there's any that may be true but
one of the reasons that true is true is
there is an absence of Democrats small D
I mean something is evolving in this
country and has been over the last
twenty years a way from the notion of
democratic self-government and even more
to the point a loss of faith in the
democratic idea I mean freedom is good
what it's not enough self-government
would be wonderful if we had the time
and the energy and the resources to
practice it but in the meantime give us
somebody who will take care of us that's
the wish for Kings the wish for Kings is
a very old wish it's the it's the wish
that brings in Caesar
the wish that brings in the men on the
white horse the magical figure that will
resolve all one's troubles and it is
antithetical to the Democratic notion of
discovering one's own future you right I
have come across only a small number of
people who can talk about any particular
book at convincing blank that is true in
in New York the Orcas that's a remark I
believe about the New York literary
world where the conversation is much
more apt to be about the author's
standing in the market I mean everybody
has read the reviews and everybody knows
whether the book is up or down or in or
out and everybody has something to say
about it in a couple of sentences but I
find at least within the court world of
the New York literary scene that
relatively few people would have the
time to read all the way through the
through the book I find that when I
travel around the country that if I'm in
California or if I'm in Ohio or Texas
and I run across somebody who's read the
book they're apt to read the whole thing
and are prepared to really talk about it
whereas in New York I get the current
opinion you had a book show on
television I did what was the name of it
it was called bookmark then it appeared
it was on public broadcasting and it was
on for three years
1989 1991 I believe what was the format
very similar to this one except it went
for half an hour we take a book just
just the way we're doing now and I would
play your part and you would play mine
and then often I would have one or two
other people in the conversation usually
writers
who had thought about or had written
about the subject under of the who could
add to the conversation and either argue
with the writer or provide a different
perspective and the object was to try to
get a conversation about ideas going in
in a half an hour if you still had the
show and you were playing my role and
you had somebody else sitting at the
table for this book what kind of person
would you invite well you'd have to
I might ask somebody like Hedrick Smith
Henry Smith wrote a book called the
power game and in public very
interesting book came out I think four
years ago and he well-known figure in
Washington this would be certainly from
the Washington side this would be a very
familiar topic to him and he would agree
with some of it and argue with some of
it but again he's very good on
television I mean he would have been a
an interesting presence what happened to
the show the show lost its funding I
mean it was supported by the Bell
Atlantic telephone company and they
supported it that company for three
years and then the people who had been
responsible for that within Bell
Atlantic went to other companies the new
people in them but Bell Atlantic had no
interest in it and I couldn't raise
money for it I tried it was at that
point was running in a hundred and forty
seven stations it was beginning to
evolve and was beginning to acquire an
audience and but I I went to various
corporations I went to
some foundations but I never could I
never could find the money to put it
back on would you think of public
television and how does that fit in the
your you know the because I know you
write some about it in the wish for Kane
I think Public Television has in my
experience of it was very much part of
the the court world in other words there
they had certain people I came up
against had certain set attitudes I mean
I brought the book show first to the
station in Washington and I was simply
told that we here at the station we're
not interested in books we never want to
hear more than three minutes a day of a
book review on NPR and we appreciate
your concern but no and this was even
with the funding presented to them I
mean I went to that meeting with the
people from Bell Atlantic and then we
encountered the same thing when we tried
to put the show on through Philadelphia
and New York was willing to take the
show but only if we dressed it up with
production values so I encountered
hostility to to books to ideas on on the
part of PBS I mean this kind of show
would be considered Talking Heads and
therefore not interested not good for
ratings not show business and I
encountered that attitude almost
wherever I went within PBS I think
they're wrong because I happen to like
Talking Heads the I think they're
interesting but and I also think that
the Public Broadcasting System should
try to do more of this kind of
because as you know there are a lot of
interesting people in the country and
and they have a lot of interesting
things to say and they don't not enough
of them appear either on certainly not
on the networks and not enough on the
public broadcasting system I've
underlined a couple of other comments
you making here about some individuals I
just want to read them and get your
reaction as to why you said that the
television and publishing media award
I'm reading this wrong the television
and publishing media award Alan
Dershowitz the reputation of an
incomparable trial lawyer in homage to
his talent for publicity rather than in
recognition of his record in appeals
cases which as of the summer of 1992
stood at nine wins and thirty nine
losses yes the the tendency again is to
go for the reputation Durga which is a
great self promoter he has won some
spectacular cases but he has lost more
than he has won but people like I
believe Leona Helmsley and then Mike
Tyson both were persuaded by his
reputation and both of them went more or
less directly to jail as I remember I
mean he didn't triumph in their cases
but again the media image the reputation
often is a surrogate for the work itself
I mean again take Kissinger and take
Nixon both of them have still
reputations as prescient statesmen
people who were clear-eyed and and saw
the shape of the world and yet if you
look back on their their record it's
like Dershowitz his record I mean they
were wrong
Vietnam they didn't understand the oil
crisis of the early 70s he certainly
didn't understand Iran or the Shah
they didn't foresee the change in Russia
it neither member understood the economy
they didn't understand what it would
mean to go off to change the gold
standard in the early 70s so that the
record is is based on to a large extent
on image and very little on on substance
Elizabeth Taylor but the media chatter
incessantly about the people from the
society has the least use about
Elizabeth Taylor's wedding or Jay Leno's
contract or Maria Shriver hair and they
returned the page and they take little
notice of people or professions on whom
the society utterly depends how come the
former figures the celebrity figures
tend to be more fun being there you know
they can be brilliantly illuminated
there they provide gossip their
decorative I mean the to keep
celebrities in a way is like keeping
pets I mean they're they're expensive
but they they they relieve people of
their own grief or their own concerns
they can it's like a great puppet show
that takes place or it's like a pageant
at court to get back to that image it's
like a masked ball and these people are
more fun to talk about and and the again
with the wonders of the modern
technology with it with a television
people throughout the country identify
with them I mean
the stars of afternoon television soap
opera shows receive a hundred thousand
letters a week from fans telling them
things that the correspondents would
never tell their fathers wives husbands
you know I mean confessional you you
write about a dinner party you were in
attendance and you're sitting next to a
lady and talking about democracy before
I ask you about that let me read this
statement you write over the course of
the last 20 years and across the span of
an extensive acquaintance among the
people who enjoy most of the country's
advantages bond salesman and politicians
as well as publishers corporate vice
presidents novelists lawyers English
professors and under secretaries of
state I have noticed that most of the
respondents fear and despise both the
theory and the practice of democracy I
think that's true I'm talking about it's
the thing I said earlier when I said
that if you asked me why did I write
this book the answer is that I've
encountered if you ask me what is the
trouble with it with the American
democracy I will say to you the absence
of Democrats and small D it is spies it
though I think they fear it maybe just
but in certain people despise it I mean
they the attitude of the the attitude
the despising takes takes the form of
the superior judgment and taste let's
say of either New York or Washington we
happy few we here in New York understand
it but they on the other side of the
Allegheny Mountains won't understand it
or we happy few here in Washington know
what is meant by but they won't know
what is meant by the sent the sorry what
about that lady I mean that the lady at
the party kind of dovetails with what
you just said yes I I'm not sure which
lady she's the one that I found myself
wondering how it is
to preserve the Democratic spirit and a
society distinguished by the Absalom
Democrats at a dinner in Washington
February I was seated next to a woman
who thought the democracy was supposed
to be easy quiet orderly peaceful and
safe right that's true by the way you
didn't name some of these people they're
going to know who they are when they
realize I would think so you get invited
back to these dinners you know oh it
could be maybe the but again that
woman's sort of thought in terms of
democracy as a 4th of July parade not as
a ceaseless argument and again the
attitude toward please no confrontation
Marva sees about confrontation it's
about you and I disagreeing with each
other it's about it's not easy it's not
orderly it's not especially safe and the
language of the court the language of
people who despise the vulgarity of too
sharp an opinion or too garish a taste
say don't want to argue you know this
woman you know was amazed to discover
that that individual property rights
could sometimes actually be in conflict
with community rights I mean this came
to her as a great news
and when I say despised and when I say a
few Democrats then you have to look at
the instinct all over the country to
sort of withdraw into enclaves take the
city of Los Angeles where you have the
people in Bel Air or in Pasadena or in
Beverly Hills living behind safe
perimeters behind walls behind their own
police forces just trying to divorce and
distance themselves
from the proletarians wandering in the
streets now that's happening all across
the country the whole advertising
business is based on the point of making
class distinctions in the term a I think
one of the things is you dish it out to
just about everybody in here and both
sides and want to make sure I get the
balance you say Bill Clinton casts
himself as a friend of the American
victim the promises he made in the name
of a custodial state could easily have
been confused with a program of diet and
exercise for a generation of lost
children an abbreviated list of his
promises reads as follows that you go
through all of his promises and earlier
you said the philosophers of the liberal
left several of whom composed Governor
Clinton's thesis of economic deliverance
believe that although money is wicked in
the hands of mere individuals it regains
its blessedness in the hands of the
state yes that's what it both believed
both left and right believe that money
is wonderful if only properly used I
mean the conservative is apt to think
that it's best left to the individual
with no government regulation or rules
and the the statist the person who says
the government knows best and therefore
if we spend the money on behalf of
others it's it's it's a different use
but it's in either instance money as
blessed only in the hands of those in
the hands of the right people however
they happen to be defined is there any
way to define your own politics at this
stage you know why after reading this
book did you conclude anything I
conclude that having writing this book
excuse me well I conclude that I I want
to get on I want to try to learn how to
describe the circumstances of the
American democracy at this point in time
in a language that's more accurate than
the one we've been using I mean one of
our difficulties this country is we
don't have a vocabulary
in which we can accurately tell each
other what we want I mean how do you
solve what are the words to solve let's
say the healthcare crisis there is no
solution until we can come to a prior
agreement as to what we expect I mean
otherwise the desire for immortality and
we now spend 600 billion a year or 7% of
our GNP and that will just continue I
mean we will bankrupt ourselves and look
because we will the desire to stay
immortal
I mean how you're going to how are we
going to control that desire that urge
unless we come to some prior agreement
as to what we're about
are you a liberal or conservative well I
would say I was culturally a
conservative but I tend to be
politically a liberal I mean I have
elements of both in them you have a
favorite present you mean other than
Lincoln and Jefferson okay they would be
my they're the ones like I probably know
what do you think of the Kennedy legacy
I think it was again as part of the wish
for Kings it's the I think there was
less there than we wish there would be
London Johnson Johnson to me was a
fascinating figure I actually met
Johnson I worked in the White House as a
in the White House you know press corps
during his briefly while he was
president and I've read quite a lot of
books about Johnson and it said I don't
have a simple answer I mean the elements
are so mixed in Johnson that that I
think he's in some ways almost a tragic
figure Jimmy Carter Carter I think is a
much better as an ex-president than he
is
as he was as a president and I misread
Carter at the time I think I the more I
know about Carter the more impressed I
am with him Ross Perot Perot I think is
a autocrat I mean I read him that way I
see him as a man who if he could run
he's very he knows what's wrong but the
way he wants to fix it to me is very
unclear and I get the uneasy feeling
with Perot that if they would like the
country to be run either you know either
as a prison or as a monastery I mean he
would be the abbot or the warden and I
don't think he's a very he has much
sense of democratic debate Reagan taught
the country that it wasn't necessary for
a president to know anything about law
or foreign policy or free speech or
trees or black people or Wales
government was a Salesman smile and a
gift for phrase a phrase I think that's
true of Reagan I think Reagan was
shrewder than many people thought but I
also think he was primarily an actor he
was a man who read a script and what the
words meant I often think he didn't know
nor did he think it wasn't I don't Star
Wars would be a wonderful example I mean
he was on his way to a budget meeting
the first budget conference the summit
and the night before Jim Baker was in
the secretary of the Treasury had given
him a briefing book and they get in the
limousine to go to the summit the next
day and Baker says to the Reagan well
did you have a chance to read the
briefing book and Reagan looked at him
in horror and said but Jim the sound of
music was odd last night of a
of course he didn't have child really I
don't think he had time I don't think he
had to be especially well-informed on
those various heads word were you born
San Francisco how long did you live
there I lived there until I was about 13
years old and then my parents moved to
New York and I came to New York and went
to school boarding school and then to
college and Connecticut what professions
were your parents about my father my
father had been in first in the shipping
business and then in the banking
business what impacted Cambridge have on
you
well Cambridge showed me the difference
between an American University of
education in English University
education I also formed and I learned to
admire CS Lewis who was then at
Cambridge and Ian Forrester was then at
Cambridge and so I I was allowed into
the presence of men whom I thought the
exemplary in many ways were you
concerned when you wrote this book that
you were stepping on a lot of toes and
that you might not be welcome in some
places that you used to go to no because
I've the people who've writing a column
a monthly column for Harper's Magazine
for a number of years I've I've already
stepped on quite a few toes so that I'm
I don't expect any new doors will be be
closed if there's there been any
reaction different reaction to this book
say then magazine I mean if people
buying this book that don't normally buy
Harper's I think so I think so I'm
beginning to get letters from people
that I that who don't aren't familiar
with what I've written and it's very
encouraging how's it selling
I think it's selling quite well what
does that mean to you what what I mean
all that means is with the
publicist tells me that the publisher
tells me that it's it's doing well and
that I don't know what that means but
presumably and I also know that people
go and ask for it and in bookstores and
it's already been sold out and it had to
order another 20 copies
what's the circulation of Harper's two
hundred and ten thousand is it making
money no Harper's last year had its best
year and since nineteen sixty two we
only lost sixty seven thousand dollars
how long you going to keep it up well I
think we it is we could keep up that
loss for quite a long time how about you
how long are you going to stay the
editor as long as I can get up in the
morning I think that it's fun to go down
to the go down to work next book next
book is about Yale University when
published the fall of 1995 our guest has
been loose